i want to talk about barcelona's cubes
because they represent one of the most
fascinating human centered attempts at
urban planning in history
in the 1800s barcelona was not a
pleasant place to live
in order to reduce the pressure of a
rising population density which
increased the likelihood for disease and
general displeasure the old walls of
barcelona that caged its population were
torn down and the council had to
organize a competition for planners to
decide how the city should expand
one of those planners was a man named
ildefons serda
he was an engineer that had his toes
dipped in politics he had a deep respect
for the working class wrote the book on
the general theory of urbanization
before urbanization was remotely cool
and even a thing and he was an active
member of the national militia and city
council of barcelona
in order to craft his magnum opus of
city planning he ended up writing one of
the most exhaustive studies on
working-class living conditions ever he
did extensive surveys of rich and poor
people
he identified a relationship between
class and space with the bourgeois
having an average of 3.6 cubic meters of
space per person while the working class
had 0.9
he analyzed interiors of homes and
studied ventilation to try and determine
optimal street widths for airflow
but his largest goal unconventional at
the time and increasingly vogue now was
to have an empirically backed rigorous
view on how to create a city centered
around public health
an independent of your taste and design
or view on urban planning it's a marvel
of human ingenuity
one of the first things you'll notice is
the straight grid pattern which is
different from traditional radial city
designs
this was a practical choice grids are
easier to navigate than circles and
they're also probably easier to build on
but it also tells you something about
serda's focus on equality
instead of making the new blocks an
extension of one main hub the old city
which would establish a hierarchical
relationship all roads point to the old
serda instead focused on uniting the
older city with seven peripheral
villages which weren't much at the time
but are now
the new city wasn't really an extension
and so much that it was just the city
this is something a radial city design
can't really do justice to
like for example in a city like paris
now that being said it would be wrong to
say he invented grids
no
that would just be wrong
but sardar's grid was unique
compared with other cities his proposal
was unique for laying out large city
blocks and spacious well-organized
intersections
he deliberated over multiple different
types of street but decided on one
mainly uniform width
according to him it wasn't a planner's
task to create artificial preferences
privileges and monopolies to the
detriment of others but what makes the
topic of street design even more
fascinating and captivating than it
already is is that he predicted the rise
of the motor car and so he designed the
minimum street with as well as the
chamfered edges so that it could meet
the advances of the next century not
only because it looked cool
and yes facilitating lots of cars is not
necessarily always seen as a good thing
especially by youtubers who like to
project their reviews on urban design to
the rest of the world
but it was still impressive that he
predicted a highly mobile form of
transport and he built a plan to match
the challenges of the next century
he had also designed provisions for
underground trains and elaborate
sanitation plans but the most remarkable
part of his plan were city blocks
the goal was to define the boundaries of
buildings on each plot of land and also
design a space that could provide
sufficient air renewal sufficient
sunlight introduce aspects of role into
urban life and allow for easy relaxed
movement for pedestrians it was not only
the edges of the blocks that would allow
for movement but it would also be within
them
blocks would also have the benefit of
being modular and easily attachable and
each block generally would have no more
than three buildings in total with an
expectation that many of the city blocks
would have two open sides the plan
presented mainly three types of block
middle courtyard the u and the l which
are incredibly advanced names i came up
with myself
in the middle of each city block would
be plenty of room for green space
designed for you know you a human it
would provide high quality air make
people feel better and it was based off
of sardar's ground values to make as
much of urban life as rural as possible
so the green space was also intended to
help produce connections for the people
living inside the buildings
he also recommended height requirements
in order for there to be adequate
sunlight but of course he had to go a
step further see when you place these
individual blocks next to each other you
can begin to construct different types
of permutations
the grid block combination allows you to
order much larger complex shapes in
order to create special areas for public
institutions like administrative and
industrial buildings cemeteries parks
and hospitals the blocks could also be
placed in a manner so that the
individual parts would create a better
hole which would encourage ventilation
and mobility across the entire city
now all of this said if you've been to
barcelona or live there you might be a
bit confused
you're probably thinking sardar's vision
with plenty of green space is not how
barcelona looks but someone random on
the internet who i always
unconditionally trust no matter what is
telling me something different
but your doubts are actually justified
accessible courtyards with plenty of
green space and open sides were the rule
in sardar's vision but today they are
the exception instead barcelona has the
luxury of having a bunch of four-sided
blocks and a lot of drunk tourists
and that's because sirda's plan was
modified multiple times
due to external pressures most buildings
were first extended parking garages were
constructed the sides would be filled up
and the height requirements would be
ignored
the result is multiple four-sided
courtyards across the entire city filled
with parking garages rather than green
space
as opposed to having multiple open
courtyards that could allow people to
walk across the entire city the
sidewalks on the side of the blocks are
practically the only option the plan was
also intended to be anything but
hierarchical but today it actually is
for many the negative repercussions of
these modifications may seem obvious but
there is a silver lining for one the
cubes of barcelona today got me to make
this video in exchange for high quality
air pedestrian mobility and a stronger
sense of community you instead get a
superficial youtube video essentially
inspired by one wikipedia article with a
reliance on much smarter academics for
my own gain
but it would also be incorrect to say
that sardar's vision failed
cities evolve and barcelona is still
changing and it's safe to say that he
laid a groundwork for where it's headed
as barcelona attempts to greenify its
city which isn't a word but still sounds
right so daw's original intentions come
in handy
not only are the courtyards being
reclaimed albeit slowly bringing back
some communal green space but the blocks
make policies such as superblocks a lot
easier which means segmenting off large
areas of city where there will be
requirements for maybe slower cars no
cars at all an investment in green
infrastructure
if the citizens of barcelona were not
able to thank serda in the 1900s and
early 21st century for the values he
tried to craft a city around
perhaps they'll be able to thank him in
the coming future before any of you
attention deficient apes click off this
video i want to give a special thank you
to professor newman i do agree with you
plannings
it's not rocket science that's correct
it's much more complex
this guy is qualified and he knows his
stuff about sir and so i would really
highly recommend you read his papers
um well just generally a lot of papers
on this you should be an informed person
anyways you get the point uh thank you
professor newman again for helping me
with this video and thanks for watching
i just repeated that because that's what
everybody else said